les etats unis tout comme l'union
européenne qui impose des sanctions
économiques à certains états maison
pleine pandémie les nations unies
appellent à assouplir ces mesures
restrictives notamment en iran ou au
venezuela
ma vie de khalifa
prise de conscience tardive utopie d'un
monde sans conflit ou réelle remise en
question des rapports de force
géopolitique cette pandémie sans
précédent remet sur la table des
négociations le débat autour des
sanctions internationales
dans la ligne de mire des états unis les
principaux pays concernés
l'iran cuba la corée du nord le
venezuela ou encore le yémen
en cette période cruciale tant pour des
raisons de santé publique mondiale que
pour appuyer les droits et la vie de
millions de personnes dans ces pays les
sanctions sectorielle doivent être
assouplies ou suspendus il est
primordial d'éviter l'effondrement du
système médical de tous pays
compte tenu de l'impact explosif que
cela aura sur le nombre de décès la
souffrance et la contagion généralisée
des veaux fort qui n'ont pas manqué de
faire réagir
mike pompéo quelques jours plus tard à
travers une conférence de presse axée
sur l'épidémie laisse entendre que les
etats-unis pourraient alléger les
sanctions contre l'iran
durement frappée par le court aux
navires us c'est aussi l'état le plus
lourdement frappée par les sanctions
américaines
en ce qui concerne l'aide humanitaire
les dispositifs médicaux les équipements
les produits pharmaceutiques les choses
dont les gens ont besoin dans les
moments difficiles ça ne fait pas
l'objet de sanctions à ma connaissance
enfin lisez simplement s'il ne s'agit
toujours pas de sanctions américaines en
corée du nord il ya des résolutions du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu dans
d'autres endroits
il s'agit plutôt de dispositions
américaines pourtant en syrie par
exemple les pressions exercées par
washington sur le secteur bancaire
syrien nuit à l'importation de matériel
médical le plaidoyer de mike pompey open
donc à convaincre du côté des nations
unies dépité par le manque de sens des
responsabilités des états unis et de la
chine qui bloque toute résolution sur la
pandémie au conseil de sécurité
187 pays de l'assemblée générale de
l'onu se sont accordés pour demander
plus de coordination dans la lutte
contre le coronavirus et de relations
multilatérales dans beaucoup de
situations parmi les plus critiques nous
n'avons pas vu de répit dans les combats
et certains conflits se sont même
intensifiées
nous avons besoin d'efforts
diplomatiques vigoureux pour relever ces
défis
pour faire taire les armes nous devons
élever la voix pour la paix est propice
j'appelle tous ceux qui peuvent faire
une différence à faire cette différence
pour exhorter et faire pression sur les
combattants du monde entier afin qu'ils
déposent les armes
il y a une chance de paix et nous en
sommes loin et le besoin est urgent de
la russie de son côté avait proposé une
résolution concurrente incluant une
demande implicite de lever général des
sanctions internationales
car l'urgence est bel et bien présente
et elle interpelle les spécialistes dans
une tribune signée le 25 mars sur le
site project syndicate un professeur de
l'université de columbia est un
économiste vénézuélien appel à une levée
des sanctions américaines contre l'iran
et le venezuela
pour eux l ont affaibli les
infrastructures de santé des deux pays
en limitant l'accès aux marchés des
devises et la capacité d'importer des
équipements médicaux clé
conclusion les sanctions contribuer à
faire de ces pays des foyers de
propagation d'épidémies